We've talked through the analytical
problem solving framework and
then covered strategies for identifying
the appropriate type of analysis or
predictive model to use
with the methodology map.
Let's put what we've
learned into action and
use the problem solving framework and
the methodology map together to
solve the business problem we mentioned
at the beginning of this course.
For a quick refresher,
your manager has tasked you with
the following business problem.
We're onboarding a new client next
month as part of a very large deal.
It's critical that we support them
with our excellent service levels.
I need to know how many tickets per
week, on average, we can expect from
this new client so we can ensure we have
enough help desk resources in place.
So let's tackle this problem.
This time, we're going to let you
start the problem solving process with
a couple of quizzes to
demonstrate your understanding.